Oui c'est ce qui arrive quand tu décides de boire un café avant de tourner une vidéo.
Alors comme ça on n'a pas dormi pendant des jours après avoir vu ma vidéo ? (rires)
*Se pète la gueule*
Quelle faiblesse, les amis, je suis récemment tombé sur un nouveau "thread"
horrifique et cette fois ce qui est flippant, c'est que ça pourrait tellement nous arriver à tous. C'est
horrible, est-ce que vous êtes prêt à ne pas dormir ? Moi oui, alors on y va ! Aujourd'hui on va parler de ce qui est arrivé
à Ryan, alias
Lustforlove sur Twitter, en Août dernier.
Décidément c'est là ou toutes les histoires d'horreur commencent apparemment.
Le mois d'Août ne sortez pas de chez vous !
Ryan s'est vu demander par son voisin de garder son chien.
Pour la modique somme de 40 dollars par jour, ce qui est carrément cool
vraiment ! Il décide de partager la nouvelle à sa communauté en disant putain ma voisine m'a demandé de garder son chien la semaine prochaine
elle m'a dit qu'elle me donnerais 40 dollars par jour et je dois le garder cinq jours. Trois jours plus tard Ryan nous dit qu'il a
rendu visite à sa voisine et que il a des trucs à nous dire. Premièrement quand il est arrivé dans la maison de sa voisine
il faisait complètement noir,
alors qu'il était 19 heures et en plein mois d'août il fait pas nuit du tout à 19h. Et quand il dit qu'il faisait complètement noir,
c'est qu'il faisait complètement noir on voyait que dalle dans la baraque. Apparemment cette dame elle a 40 ans et elle vit seule dans
une maison immense.
Ryan nous indique qu'il n'a pas de problème avec ça, qu'il ne juge pas, mais c'est toujours effrayant de voir quelqu'un qui
vit seul dans un endroit 10 fois trop grand pour lui.
Non pas qu'on est jaloux ou quoi mais on se dit putain il vit seul là-dedans ça lui
fout pas le cafard, ou alors ça se trouve il n'était pas seul et sa famille est morte. Il nous dit ensuite qu'il était un
peu en flippe parce qu'elle parlait d'une manière bizarre et dès qu'elle parlait elle avait besoin de toucher des parties de son corps, à Ryan.
Très bizarre, très tactile la dame. Ryan nous cache pas et qui passe un très mauvais moment quand il la rencontre mais il se dit
bats les couilles c'est que pour cinq jours et je vais me faire de l'argent allez on y va
la dame finit donc enfin par l’amener dans une pièce sombre dans laquelle se trouve le chien dans une petite cage. La dame lui dit
alors de le garder dans la cage quand il s'en occupe, et le laisser sortir uniquement quand il a besoin de faire pipi et il
se dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel ? Un chien il n'est pas fait pour être en cage d'une pièce sombre et humide
Tu le laisses gambader dans ton jardin,
je sais pas un chien c'est un être vivant comme nous, il a besoin de kiffer sa vie un peu. Ouais je passe un
message ouais, OK. Alors il continue de parler, et la dame lui dit qu'elle a déjà dû faire appel à des gens pour s'occuper de son chien
mais que certains d'entre eux l'ont
empoisonné elle a donc dû s'occuper de leur cas. Des gens qui ont empoisonné son chien qu'est ce que tu veux dire par là ?
A ce moment-là ryan se dit qu'il va laisser le boulot à quelqu'un d'autre que c'est beaucoup trop glauque, beaucoup trop bizarre l'ambiance dans cette
maison comment elle est cette dame
et puis au final il pense à l'argent il se dit franchement y'en a que pour cinq jours, je vais m'occuper d'un chien qu'elle traîte
probablement comme une merde. Une fois le boulot terminé je la reverrai plus jamais de ma vie,  bats les couilles allez j'y vais.
Ryan rentre chez lui, on est le 15 août et il commence à garder le chien le 16 août donc le lendemain et nous fait une petite
blague, il nous dit de ne pas nous inquiéter, qu'il réussira à trouver où elle cache les cadavres des gens qu'elle a tués.
bonne blague Ryan, bonne blague, attend donc de passer la nuit seul dans cette maison. nous sommes le 16 août Ryan va chez sa voisine
il nous met suite une petite vidéo de lui qui marche dans la maison et
effectivement cette putain de maison elle fout le cafard mec, quel cauchemar putain on croirait la maison dans Resident Evil 7 tu sais où il se retrouve
au milieu d'une famille glauque je suis sûr que c'est cette maison là qu'il y à dans le jeu. On va pas se mytho, c'est aussi la manière dont c'est
filmé, il est avec son téléphone
en mode flash et ça rend tout glauque. Bref, il fait un petit tour dans les chambres voir si y'a personne il prend des
petites photos pour nous montrer mais il met une vidéo d'un truc qui retient quand même son attention puisque c'est extrêmement glauque
Mec, pourquoi il y a une poupée assise sur une chaise
qui regarde le lit ? c'est probablement la même chaise d'ailleurs que celle où David s'assoit la nuit. Tout est glauque regarde le matelas gros
y'a pas de draps dessus, c'est deux matelas empilés, même l'horloge et le tableau ils sont posés par terre sur la moquette, ils sont plus accrochés
accrochés au mur mec, c'est trop bizarre !
à ce moment là tout le monde à Ryan de se barrer y'a même une meuf qui dit tu peux vivre même sans les 200
dollars mais tu ne peux pas vivre si tu n'es plus en vie cours
Elle a raison.
Ryan continue de faire un petit tour de la maison c'est normal il va y dormir pendant quatre jours il a plutôt intérêt à être
au courant de ce qu'il ya dedans il nous dit que toutes les pièces de la maison
sont ouvertes sauf une seule dont il n'a pas la clé selon lui cette pièce mène au sous-sol, sous sol dans lequel se trouve
peut-être les gens que cette dame a tué je sais pas ! Ryan remarque aussi quelque chose d'autre c'est que depuis qu'il est arrivé dans la
maison il y'a un vieux poste radio qui fait du bruit qui grésille, comme si vous savez elle l'avait mis entre deux stations donc il y a
pas de musique ça fait juste du bruit c'est juste flippant gratuitement. Ryan prend une autre photo d'une des bibliothèques de la maison dans laquelle
se trouve beaucoup de livres de
républicains extrémistes blancs
Ryan se dit que c'est bien le genre de personne qui serait capable de commettre des meurtres. Ryan nous envoie ensuite une vidéo dans laquelle
il pense avoir entendu un bruit venant de derrière une porte à vous d'en juger
Clairement là il faut partir en courant ! Il faut arrêter de faire comme dans les films d'horreur là quand le perso principal il entend du
bruit on sait clairement que c'est un esprit qui veut lui couper la tête mais il y va quand même on sait jamais, mais part
en courant !!
Putain ça m'énerve ça; quelqu'un lui répond en disant n'ouvre pas la porte tant que tu n'es pas absolument certain que c'est une
personne réelle derrière et pas un esprit et un autre mec lui dit mais il traverse les murs les esprits putain
je trouve ça drôle désolé ça me fait du bien ça me fait décompresser là de cette histoire de merde encore d'horreur là. Ryan nous dit
ensuite que l'un de ses followers a remarqué un truc bizarre avec la poupée sur la vidéo qu'il a mise alors il décide de retourner
pour checker de ses propres yeux
Ryan poste alors une vidéo en disant qu'il était en chemin pour la pièce où il y à la putain de poupée de ces morts et
il a entendu un bruit venir du plafond plus précisément venir de la ventilation
Mais arrête
fuis gros et le chien dans l'histoire gros, t'es là pour t'occuper du chien mec t'es même pas avec lui non mais c'est vrai quoi ! Ryan nous dit qu'il
a une nouvelle fois entendu un bruit venir de la porte d'entrée de la maison et décide de prendre une vidéo à travers l'oeil de
la porte pour nous prouver qu'il ya bien personne devant la putain de maison
Putain, je deviens parano avec ces vidéos là ! Le chien a envie d'aller dehors pour faire ses besoins mais Ryan nous dit qu'il a trop peur d'ouvrir
n'importe quelle porte de la maison y compris la porte d'entrée donc ça va attendre
on peut clairement le comprendre, on ferait la même dans sa situation mais franchement le chien je le mets dans l'évier ou
au-dessus des toilettes tu vas te démerder tu vas apprendre à faire pipi comme un humain pendant cinq jours voilà après je me casse
c'est bon non vraiment c'est chaud
Ryan a fait une autre découverte il se trouve que sous l'un des lits dans une pièce il y a des putains de clous. Pff, elle montait
un meuble Ikea elle a fait tomber quelques outils elle a pas fait gaffe
J'espère
Ryan pourquoi tu ne pars pas en courant mais explique nous, ah  tu n'as pas de jambes, bah il fallait le dire
18 minutes après qui paraît une éternité pour les gens qui suivaient le thread en direct Ryan donne des nouvelles idées qu'il est toujours vivant
et que quelque chose est arrivé il dit qu'il a
entendu quelque chose tomber par terre dans la pièce où se trouve la poupée et nous rappelle qu'il n'a touché à rien dans cette pièce
qu'il n'a bougé aucun objet il décide alors plutôt que de rentrer chez sa mère en chialant en appelant la police de retourner dans
la pièce où il y a la poupée pour voir ce qui s'est passé.Vidéo.
Vous l'avez vu ou pas
regardez bien par rapport à la vidéo qu'on a vu tout à l'heure un truc à changer la tête de la poupée a bougé cette
cette salope de poupée à bougé c'est
horrible un des followers de Ryan a eu une bonne idée en lui demandant de regarder dans les étagères où il ya des bouquins s'il ya
un bouquin sur le paranormal
peut-être que ça pour indiquer que la propriétaire de la maison elle fait des trucs un peu bizarres des rites où on sait pas trop
quoi et ça pourrait expliquer ces phénomènes paranormaux ou pas que pour l'instant Ryan n'arrive pas à expliquer lui-même et devinez quoi
il en trouve un et nous envoie une petite photo de ce bouquin
Ryan se rend compte qu'il est seulement minuit alors qu'il a l'impression que ça fait six heures qu'il est dans cette putain de maison il
dit alors qu'il veut pas être comme la fille qui meurt dans tout les films d'horreur mais il demande aux gens s'il doit rester ou
pas pendant l'heure la plus flippante qui est de minuit à 1h du mat'. Il se met à revoir des tas de messages de gens qui
lui disent mec prends tes cliques et tes claques le chien et fuit et certains de ces messages le font vraiment
flipper notamment un mec qui lui indique s'y connaître pas mal
en tout ce qui est sorcellerie et paranormal et que mettre des clous son espace de vie intime peut vouloir dire plusieurs choses soit que
la personne essaye de repousser quelque chose de sérieux et d'agressif ou alors qu'il y a des zones maudite dans la maison Ryan décide alors de
se barrer de la maison. On ne sait pas s'il a pris le chien ou pas, on ne sait pas si tout ça est vrai mais putain ce
que c'est flippant les amis n'hésitez pas à aimer cette vidéo si vous voulez dormir
j'suis un escroc je trouve ce thread
génial parce que ça peut tellement nous arriver des jobs d'été où tu dois garder un enfant tu dois garder un chien bref tu
dois aller dans un autre endroit une autre maison et tu découvres les lieux et tu découvres avec les lieux des trucs qui
sont un peu bizarres qui font que t'es pas très serein quand même et puis tout part en vrille et en plus à cela s'ajoute
la paranoïa et c'est terrible quoi dans ces situations tu deviens parano de fou mec, t'a plus aucune objectivité pour toi tout veut du mal et
tout est vilain
j'espère que ça vous aura plu c'est un peu différent des deux sets qu'on avait déjà fait mais j'aime bien varier un petit
peu les plaisirs si je puis dire dans celui-là ce que j'aime bien c'est qu'on n'a pas la fin le mec est pas allé jusqu'au
bout n'est pas resté et c'est cool il a pas été le personnage
héroïque d'un film d'horreur qui est con et qui meurt ça fait plaisir on peut être que content pour Ryan selon vous qu'est ce qu'il
y avait dans cette putain de maison mais moi je trouve juste que l'histoire de la poupée c'est trop flippant
Ryan il a jamais dit si tout ça était fake ou pas mais en tout cas ça a l'air tellement
vrai ça a l'air encore plus vrai que les deux autres  thread, je trouve ces horribles du coup c'est un peu moins flippant mais comme ça
à l'air grave vrai bah c'est plus flippant en fait au final voilà je suis en pls comme à chaque fin de vidéos comme ça au
moins il est 18 heures il fait bien jours c'est bon j'suis bien on est loin de l'orage de la nuit la dernière fois.
Bah je vous fais des bisous et qu'est ce que je vous souhaite la bonne nuit allez ciao
Bonne nuit !